on the mound for the blue jays with a
record of 1-0 and a 1.40 era making his
second start of the season left the
stephen mats
leadoff fitter retired now for shohei
otani who had another big night
yesterday in game two of the series a
homer four runs batted in
there's a drive out to right for a busy
randall grichik who lays out and can't
get to it ball checks up and hits him in
the face
ohtani will get in a second easily and
cut it all the way to third with a
one-out triple
right on cue maddie and you were talking
about what happened and it's just
anchoring those feet when he does that
he's able to stay on the ball longer and
you do things like this
cover the other half and hook the
baseball ball look at the back foot
steady there dives and this one ends up
going off the glove and his head before
end up being a triple second of the
season for shohei ohtani showing that
speed
right on the inside corner and random as
he's done often in this series
questioning the cold strength but matz
has been working on that inside quarter
he had a lot of great movement on that
pitch this fastball's got that natural
movement where it can come back on the
plate you can see that he was thinking
with him and he changed speeds with him
so rindon is retired trout still at
first ohtani's at third two outs and
here is the future hall of famer albert
pujols
this is a ground ball big hop for
machete he's got plenty of time and
steven matz
pitches around a one out triple
looking to get his angel debut in the
rearview mirror as soon as he can
is the 10-year veteran left-hander
colombian-born jose quintana an all-star
in 2016 is white sock
2-2 from quintana
got him looking
boy he painted that fastball on the
inside part of the plate 92 he'll rush
his fastball 90-94
slider
slash curveball as well but his change
up his go-to as far as getting
strikeouts but when you paint like that
you're going to get the punch out simeon
was looking away possibly looking for
the change up
and that is a called third strike and
that one was on the outside corner
fastball gets him looking and the inning
will end they leave runners at first and
third here in the bottom of the first
one in one to the catcher kurt suzuki
little roller up the third base line
bare handed by espinar what a nice play
santiago espinal making his first start
of the season he was just activated
prior to the game and bear hands it and
throws out the catcher to end the top of
the second
nifty play at third santiago espal made
a nice play to in the top of the second
he'll lead things off for the blue jays
and pat it's been a very special day for
espanol he was activated he's in the
stunning lineup but he's had maybe the
treat of his lifetime yeah pre-game
vladimir guerrero got to go out there
and he talked to albert poulos he said
listen i got a young kid who really
admires you i want to introduce you to
him and he gets to meet albert pujols
and if you've never talked to albert
pujols he is one of the most genuine
persons you ever want to
there's know little loop that's gonna
get down for a base hit lead off single
for espanol
he met his hero before the game now he
gets to stand next to him at first base
look at the smile on his face the pool
said hey man
they didn't tell me you could hit two
that's got 3 000 of those things
so jansen two for 14 this year
jackson hits it on the ground pujols
goes to second for one back to first
hand that ball slipped out of the hand
as the runner comes in to score jansen
goes to second
and now joe baden is asking for time and
a review on that play
because iglesias
he looked like he got spiked at second
base and threw very poorly halfway to
first after getting the throw from
pujols espinal comes into the score at
least for the time being
so here's the play throw high glacis was
past second when he caught the ball so
davis is safe
jonathan did a great job of running
towards second you could see him peek
over his shoulder and he was in the
throwing lane of pujols then he makes
contact and glaciers was off the back so
he is safe at second because he could
reach the base on his slide now marcus
simeon with the bases loaded to run in
and again nobody out
got him
made him chase
under the strike zone
and that's a big first out for jose
quintana so bobachet now with the bases
loaded
ball four he walked the run in
so quintana has lost his control he has
walked three already
and he walked in another run guerrero
takes ball four three nothing blue jays
randall griczyk got a base hit his first
time up
base hit down the left side it could be
extra bases palacios in the score here
comes bishop they're waving guerrero
around third and he'll score without a
throw rando bridgette clears the bases
with his second hit of the night
looked like it might have been a slider
that he tries to slide in there
yeah down and in right where he likes it
and he shoots it past rendon at third
base for three runs
it's a good matchup for gretchen
two outs
that's a fair ball just inside the bag
at first glitching jogs home espinal
will be stopped at first
but he picks up his second hit of the
inning and his first rbi of the season
and that's going to be it for
jose quintana
davis sends a drive the other way
lagaris has it to put a merciful end to
a seven run bottom of the second
ship walk to the bases loaded in that
seven running second inning
hits it that's a fair ball past random
down the left field line bostios is
around to score they're going to wave
simeon around as well
and beau beshett
drives in two more tonight and the blue
jays are jumping all over the angels
early in this ball game just what the
doctor ordered for the blue jays offense
hit with runners in scoring position
they haven't done a good job of that
take the walks when the pitchers don't
challenge you they've done a good job of
that
second hit by the jays down into that
corner that's going to score multiple
runners matty guerrero step in against
jaime berea
base it to left field bow's going to be
waved around third upton will not make a
throw as vlad has had a perfect night at
the plate and the blue jays have put up
a 10 spot against the angels
it'll be rendon pujols and upton here
for the angels steven matt's all kinds
of support tonight
rendon lifts off a drive into left and
that one's gonna go
anthony rendon's first homer of the year
and the angels are on the scoreboard in
the top of the fourth yeah a lot of
success
by a redone against mats and also his
first home run on the road believe it or
not as an angel all nine home runs last
year at the big a first on the road for
anthony rendon
base hit to right field
espinar will jog home as blasia has had
a big night
he's two for two
picks up his first big league rbi with a
single two
right field
oh shoots went down the right side this
is trouble that's a fair ball up against
the fence palace is in the score
here comes simeon right behind the
throat of the plate not in time have a
big night bo
five rbis for the blue jays shortstop
his second double of the night
and the blue jays have blown it wide
open
hits it hard off the glove of fletcher
that ball ate him up here comes bo
around third he'll score
david fletcher
backed up and a ball went off his glove
into right field
i believe that could be scored a base
hit
too hot to handle jose rojas came in
defensively in left field he's batting
in the spot of justin upton
this is hit in the air playable jonathan
davis over
and makes the catch and stephen metz
leaves a base runner so he will give
the blue jay six very good innings joe
panic getting his first plate appearance
for the ball game
there's a ground ball through the right
side that's going to go into the
outfield palacios is coming around third
here's the throw to the plate not in
time
joe panic picks up an rbi
for panic that's his first rbi of the
season and it's 15 to
tommy malone pitched on tuesday in texas
three innings a run on three hits two
walks and two strikeouts
pujo swings and misses and strikes out
that was a change up in the 70s you can
see albers talking to himself
what was that
pitch
drag three call rojas called out on
strikes i'm not tommy malone five
strikeouts just
come out of that pin give me some
innings trying to finish off this game
throw strikes here's another 2-2 pitch
from malone
called strike three
this is called out on strikes how about
tommy malone's relief after picking up
his third career save ends up with six
strikeouts and three innings in the blue
jays as a team
scored 15 runs